hi there Steve Kaufman here again today
I'm going to stray a little bit from my
usual focus on language learning and I'm
going to talk about education in general
I'm going to talk about universities and
specifically referred to the strikes
that were experiencing here in Canada in
the province of Quebec where university
students have been striking for weeks
now in protest against the government in
Canada the education is provincial there
is dick jurisdiction and the Quebec
government decided that the university
fees the fees that the students page
should increase from can't remember
exactly but three thousand two hundred
fifty dollars a year to 3756 I've done
it goes out three hundred dollars or
something which is less than is paid in
the other provinces in Canada which I
think average around five thousand
dollars and significantly less than the
cost of a university education because
the government pays most of the costs
and once you add in all the professors
and the buildings and the research and
everything else it's about 25 to 30
thousand dollars a year that it cost to
put someone through university the
students are paying 3,000 whatever so
first of all to me it's absolutely
ludicrous that these students who are
being subsidized to the tune of you know
eighty-five percent of their university
education are striking they say I'm not
going to go to this class that the rest
of the taxpayers have paid for me to
attend I'm going to stay home and what's
more they are then quite violent in the
streets overturning cars preventing
other students from going to class and
their professors many of them have
expressed great support for these
students you know great leaders of
tomorrow blah blah blah well to my mind
those professors shouldn't get paid as
long as those students are not going to
class because the rest of the society is
paying for that service and paying for
these students to go to class the
reality is that the majority of students
at universities come from middle
class and more affluent families so in
fact it's a transfer it's it's going
into the sort of tax revenues of the
state and deciding that we're going to
give X amount of this to people who are
already better off than the average and
probably you know did better at school
there for maybe have other advantages in
terms of their ability to learn academic
subjects those people are going to end
up doing better in society that's proven
that people with university education on
balance statistically do better so
they're going to end up with more income
but as society has been subsidizing
these people but the students now feel
not enough we need more subsidies so
it's really about money it's not about
ideals they're not out there
demonstrating for peace or four I don't
know the environment they're saying I
don't want to have to pay more than what
I'm paying I think other people should
pay more for me I find I find that is
not a position that I have any great any
great sympathy for uh you know this has
nothing to do with providing bursaries
and scholarships for for students who
come from families that can't afford it
but unfortunately in most countries
statistically the kids that end up in
University come from the families that
are already better off for a variety of
reasons large they having to do with the
fact that better educated people tend to
do better in society better educated
people tend to me you know more ready to
insist that their kids study harder and
so their kids do study harder and
therefore their kids do better and
therefore the 30 University and so forth
and so on okay that's point number one I
have no sympathy for those people number
two someone said that 75% of parents
want their kids to go to university
twenty-five percent of jobs require a
university education so a lot of these
people are at University and they will
end
and jobs that in fact do not require a
university education what's more eighty
percent or so of the students I don't
know what the number is but certainly of
the undergraduates and a lot of the
people who are demonstrating in Quebec
are undergraduates they study sociology
history language linguistics psychology
commerce soft essentially soft subjects
apparently their comment was made and I
don't know this you're not but the
engineering students the science
students are not out there demonstrating
its the sociology students the political
science students etc that are out there
demonstrating now what exactly is it
that they learn why do they need to go
to university I went to university I
went to see on spoke it was less did
unity politique in Paris I mean I went
to the art class didn't have to at the
end of the year they published what was
called a Polly cookie which was a
because we had a stenographer take notes
during all the lectures we could buy the
course what the professor had the sager
in the year and so we read those so
during the year I would do a reading on
a wide range of study subjects this is
political science international
relations international trade whatever
it might be I would do a lot of reading
in French of course and then when it
came close to exam time I would read
what the professor has to say because I
knew had to get him back when he said
otherwise I couldn't get a very good
mark so you know but I didn't need to be
at the school and so today you know I
could get the equivalent of this Polly
copy a this telegraphed you know course
from the best professors and there are
universities that are putting courses up
online the University of Texas at Austin
so far as languages tremendous resources
for language learning MIT and others so
why you know what the students in quebec
should be protesting about is not the
fact that they have to pay 3,500 or 600
instead of 3,000 GN why does it cost so
much money for them to take these
courses what I think we should do is we
everyone not just the few that are able
to get into University we should give
everyone $10,000 as your per year for
four years let's say total of call it
$50,000 this is your post this you
graduate from high school you get 50
thousand dollars you can spend it on any
valid post-secondary education that you
want to take and so then you have to
qualify so that if you study online at
MIT that's good if you study online that
you know you're you studying language
you study University of Texas at Austin
that's good if you study at link that's
good you know whatever you choose to do
that's good you know if you're studying
languages or if you're studying
sociology you know read books you have
this money to spend and then there
should be a separate testing
organization where people have to write
essays actually write them and where
they're tested on their knowledge in
these subjects now when it comes to
science and engineering and so forth now
that's a different story and there I
think those people should be that should
be free if you want to study engineering
if you want to study the hard sciences
which we require if we want to have an
innovative society we need innovators we
need people who understand those things
and those people their education should
be free but the eighty percent of people
who go to university today today and
study you know gender studies and the
history of I don't know what that's over
and so on all these courses which very
often they take because they couldn't
get into the ones that they didn't want
that they wanted to you know attend they
should be able to study it wherever they
want and they shouldn't have to go to a
university that cost thirty thousand
dollars a year it just it just doesn't
make sense and if those people who are
you know unhappy to have to spend you
know the daily their parents or whoever
gonna have to spend three thousand six
hundred a year if those people have to
spend a full shot they wouldn't go they
wouldn't go and a good example you know
of a good education system from what I
can tell is in Germany where fewer
people fewer students go to university
much higher number learn a trade and if
I look at people that I've known in say
the forest industry whoo-hoo market wood
products many of them have studied wood
products the marketing of what products
they have learned a trade that because
all these other books reading about Noam
Chomsky and all those other stuff you
can do it on your own you don't need
necessarily to be in a class not a lot
of people say you know the university is
a wonderful place to meet people need
you know your future spouse and so forth
and you know very good stimulating and
stuff like that fine so why are we only
saying that you know thirty forty
percent of the population gets that
privileged paid for by the taxpayers at
the expense of hospital beds I you know
schools in the primary sector where we
have a lot of people graduating who
can't read properly we take money away
from that and we give it to these people
so they can have a good time I don't
understand that argument but that's what
you hear all the time of course the
other thing is that the universities
issue tickets if you get a degree that's
going to guarantee you a better job
regardless of the content you know of
what you actually learn none of that
really matters you have a diploma now
you're going to get a better job so we
should take the diploma issuing a
function away from the institutions that
deliver the education and so if you need
together a diploma you need to
demonstrate that you know XYZ or that
you can express yourself well or that
you speak a language or you're familiar
with whatever go and write the test and
it shouldn't matter whether you learned
it online or at the library or wherever
it just make these tests very rigorous
and so that the the the sort of issuing
of the ticket to success shouldn't be
you know sort of the monopoly of these
universities that are bloated and
inefficient and a big drain on our GDP
so there you have it as you probably
know by now I tend to get quite
opinionated on
a lot of these subjects and I that's
certainly my take I put that forward for
discussion and I look forward to your
comments thank you for this